[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 débat deux mois après le premier
acte d gilet jaune
le président emmanuel macron a lancé le
15 janvier le grand débat national
jusqu'à la mi mars les françaises et les
français sont invités à y participer par
le biais de cahiers de doléances mis à
disposition dans les mairies ou bien en
participant à des réunions publiques
ce grand débat national et il est la
réponse à la crise sociale que traverse
notre pays
à quoi va-t-il servir concrètement pour
y répondre quatre invités en plateau
didier baichère bonsoir vous êtes député
la république en marche pour la première
circonscription à des yvelines à vos
côtés et joséphine coleman ce berger
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes maire les
républicains de plaisir vous est
également membre de génération terrain
et puis en face de vous loïc et damien
bonsoir vous êtes membre gilet jaune
mouvement citoyen des clés et alentours
alors dimanche soit deux jours avant le
coup d'envoi de ce grand débat emmanuel
macron s'est adressé à la population en
publiant à cette lettre
qu'en avez-vous pensé aujourd'hui
effectivement c'est je pense que c'est
on va dire c'est une première ainsi en
termes d'initiatives prises par le
gouvernement effectivement de prendre
l'initiative d'envoyer une lettre à
chacun des français
je pense que ça a été perçu
majoritairement comme un peu un effet
contradictoire par rapport à la crise
quand on a train de traverser bon sens
où effectivement aujourd'hui on nous
demande essentiellement de faire
beaucoup d'économies a restreintes
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
aujourd'hui on va dépenser une somme
assez importante pour l'envoi de ces
deux têtes là bon sachant qu'aujourd'hui
on a beaucoup numériser le
les échanges et je pense que peut-être
une plateforme effectivement avec un
avec un document rédigé numériquement
aurait suffi quoi je pense que c'était
peut-être un peu maladroit en tout cas
de prendre cette insee silva et de faire
le choix d'envoyer une lettre papier
gilet jaune pardon disent que la seule
lettre qui intéresse est les français
c'est la lettre de démission des manuels
maintenant est ce que vous partagez cet
avis ou pas aujourd'hui je suis pas le
plénipotentiaire des idées zone donc je
veux dire chacun chacun pense esquisse
qui veut effectivement mais je trouve
effectivement que cette lettre n'a été
effectivement un acte de ma grossesse
plutôt que comme un berger vous avez en
plus apte à être avec vous qu'avec les
cons avez-vous pensé à côté pour pour
répondre à ce que vous venez de dire il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ne vont pas sur
internet et qui ont quand même besoin
d'avoir un papillon ça il faut il faut
l'imaginer cheveux en train de défendre
du tout quoi que ce soit simplement dans
la forme
moi ce qui est important s'il ya dedans
c'est ça qui m'intéresse donc
effectivement on peut se rendre compte
qu'il ya des axes qui ont été données
parce que la difficulté était grande
d'entendre de la part des gilet jaune
que j'ai j'ai suivi et que je respecte
bien sûr mais est bien là la substance
même des deux banques puisqu'elles
étaient très diverses et variées donc
j'ai l'impression que cette lettre bien
sûr répond en partie en tout cas à des
grands axes qui ont été un petit peu
évoquée par les gilet jaune ces
dernières semaines maintenant est ce que
elle va apporter je dirais la réponse et
les réponses que vous en attendez et que
nous en attendons j'en suis pas si
certaine que cela
en tout cas sachez que en ce qui nous
concerne les élus puisqu'on l'a dit
monsieur macron quand on l'a rencontré
eh bien on lui a dit que nous étions en
tout cas les relais au niveau des mers
et nous allons faire le nécessaire pour
que cette lettre soit connue et soit
qu'augmenter et surtout bien qu'on y
apporte bien sûr des réponses avant le
15 mai alors on va parler évidemment de
ce qu'il ya dans cette lettre dans
quelques instants notamment des thèmes
qui ont été retenus didier baichère en
tant que des pics que député quel va
être votre rôle justement dans ce grand
débat national de notre rôle c'est
d'écouter de continuer à écouter moi je
crois que ce mouvement d
gilet jaune il a il a révélé deux choses
extrêmement importantes y avait une
revendication très forte initiale sur le
pouvoir d'achat et ça je pense qu'on a
répondu en responsabilité avec les 10
milliards d'euros donc sur l'accueil
d'activités je vais revenir sur toutes
les mesures et surtout cette deuxième
partie des revendications qui et comment
je peux participer moi en tant que
citoyen plus directement à la vie de la
nation donc la volonté de débattre et
donc c'est la réponse que kate apportées
dans cette lettre c'est la vision
politique du président de la république
et de l'ensemble du gouvernement pour
enclencher ce grand débat national qu'on
estime nécessaire en tout cas demandé
par une grande partie des gens qui ont
qui ont manifesté et puis qui va
s'ouvrir non pas uniquement parce que
j'ai souvent entendu ça uniquement au
gilet jaune n'y a pas que les gilet
jaune qui vont venir débattre dans ces
réunions mais c'est l'ensemble des
françaises et des français qui sont
appelés à venir débattre
donc ça va être très différent j'ai
envie de dire suivant les territoires il
ya des mères qui tout de suite se sont
engagés sur le cahier des propositions
qui propose déjà des réunions moi sur ma
circonscription nous sommes en
discussion avec les trois maires
montigny guyancourt et versailles 2 qui
aura probablement une réunion qui sera
organisée sur un lieu emblématique de
saint quentin en yvelines où on invitera
tous les saint quentinois et où les
versaillais à venir débattre échanger
c'est pas une des réunions ces sages
insiste où les françaises et les
français vont pouvoir venir poser des
questions aux élus s'agit d'organiser un
débat ou dire entrer si toi d'être
citoyen je suis pour l' isf je suis
contre l'idée sf et c'est bien que les
deux parties puissent s'entendre et nous
par contre notre rôle sera d'animer le
débat mais également de consigner
l'ensemble des débats et des
propositions qui ont lieu dans les
réunions pour les faire remonter des
voiliers tout est indiqué justement
cadres et j'ai envie de dire ses
doléances ces débats quatre thèmes ont
été retenus il y à la transition
écologique la fiscalité les dépenses
publiques la démocratie et la
citoyenneté
l'organisation a de l'état et des
services publics loïc et damien vous
vous en pensez quoi de cette charge est
un petit peu habitués à ce que vous
dites c'est que
pour moi le grand débat il a commencé il
ya bien longtemps en fait le grand débat
n'a pas commencé quand l'initiative a
été prise par le gouvernement
je pense que les revendications étaient
claires en fin du mois se sont
clarifiées avec le temps parce
qu'effectivement c'est difficile de
synthétiser et coordonner un ensemble de
personnes et d'en extraire en fait les
vraies revendications
donc pour moi le débat il a commencé il
ya bien longtemps en amont et
aujourd'hui bas quand j'entends
effectivement qu'on dit bas
il ya des questions qui doivent être
posées non nous il ya des réponses qui
doivent être apportées
et c'est ça qui est important en fait
c'est on en est plus à l'heure des
questions on n'a pas de question à
proprement parler a demandé au
gouvernement ce qu'on veut c'est des
réponses à nos questions et à nos
revendications qu'elle soit positive ou
négative initiée il ya des questions je
pense qu'ils seront évoqués par la suite
loïc par exemple vous si vous aviez des
questions justement à poser ce serait
lequel
déjà pour commencer
je suis d'accord avec le collègue moi ce
qui me chagrine dans ce que vous dites
le débat national a commencé déjà depuis
que les gilet jaune donc les français
mobilisés devrait agir on dépose et donc
on commence à se mobiliser
d'accord il est forcé de constater que
le président de la république son
gouvernement les députés de la
république en marche ont mis du temps à
répondre
il aurait pu éviter tout ça il aurait pu
éviter la colère il aurait pu éviter
tous ces blessés
s'émeut français françaises mobilisées
blessés mutilés
d'accord je ne pensé pas
particulièrement pompiers 47 ans qui a
été blessée à bordeaux mis dans un coma
artificiel par exemple entre autres on
aurait pu éviter tous à éviter cette
colère la réponse trop tardive à se
lancent par div
même si les 10 milliards par exemple ils
auraient pu les proposer dès le début on
a perdu on a perdu du temps on perd du
temps aujourd'hui
oui même si c'est une petite de petites
réformes
à mon sens parce que j'en parle je parle
à mon nom en ont ils auraient pu le
faire tout de suite dès le début on
aurait pu gagner du temps c'est je
trouve c'est une perte de temps alors je
reviens sur sur les thèmes alors
emmanuel macron l'a répété il n'y a pas
de sujet tabou il ya quand même 35
questions qui sont proposés dans cette
lettre a par exemple on n'entend pas
parler de l' isf pourquoi il est cher
mais le côté pas tabou dans les dents
les questions est important lui il a
donné sa vision sur 35 points qui lui
semblait légitime et qui revenait dans
les discussions qui avait été soulignée
par a pas parlé gilet jaune dont il
désappointé mais quand vous faites une
fin d'où les élus ont fait ça tout le
temps quand vous faites une réunion
publique
vous dites pas à l'avancé aux gens ce
sur quoi ils vont parler donc il ya une
expression sur des thèmes principaux qui
sont attendus qui ont été classés cédé 4
thèmes dont vous avez parlé et ensuite
on va consigner l'ensemble des demandes
vous savez après honnêtement moi je me
vois pour avoir ouvert un cahier de
propositions numérique sur sur mon site
internet depuis pas mal de semaines
très très globalement ce qui revient
c'est le pouvoir d'achat est vraiment en
tête de liste et toutes les comptes
questions autour des candidats des
institutions comment un moment donné je
peux participer mieux au débat à quoi
servent les élus comment ils vont
comprendre ce débat là et comment il me
représente mieux
moi je me résoudrai comme sale et enfin
en tout cas sur ceux qui se sont
exprimés sur sur mon cahier de
propositions
voilà ce qui revient je pense que c'est
des choses qui vont qui vont être sur la
table
maintenant par rapport à ce que vous
dites je pense que le débat il a
commencé bien entendu avec les
revendications des filets jaunes et je
crois qu'on a on a écouté on a entendu
beaucoup de choses maintenant l'ensemble
des françaises et des français doivent
s'exprimer
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui fait une
république et une démocratie quand vous
dites moi j'attends la démission de
monsieur m'accroche je suis désolé c'est
une manifestation anti républicaine le
président de la république il est élu
pour cinq ans démocratiquement auxerre
on n'est pas dans une enfin on est dans
un pays où on peut voter pas voté fin
extrêmement libre les français ont
choisi un programme un président de la
république donc emmanuel macron il est
là et il exécute le programme pour
lequel il a été élu et il écoute
à un moment donné un mouvement et il va
proposer des améliorations par rapport à
ce que les françaises et les français
vont dire alors concernant les
contributions donc les citoyens pourront
les faire à partir du 21 janvier sur un
site sur le site grand débat point fr
pour l'instant donc les citoyens peuvent
se rendre en mairie joséphine mme
coleman ce berger vous avez mis en place
j'imagine un cahier de doléances comment
ça se passe à plaisir
on n'a pas mis en place un cahier de
doléances parce que l'expression ne me
plaît pas c'est plutôt un un cahier
d'idées pour la france avec également
une urne dans laquelle avec des couleurs
différentes les gens vont pouvoir
répondre aux quatre points qui ont été
demandés par par le président donc c'est
en place on a mis un facebook exprès
pour que les personnes puissent répondre
et puis également offrir un grand débat
aussi à plaisir au mois de mars pour
pouvoir présenter le bilan des remontées
au niveau de la population
mais ce que je voudrais dire aussi c'est
que je vous rejoins bien sûr que les
problématiques elles sont
longue date ça je peux vous dire que
bien avant même que tout ce mouvement se
met en place
on avait des remontées très très
difficile de la population avec des
difficultés qui était très grande et et
puis tout est parti sur l'augmentation
du gazoil faut quand même le reconnaître
c'est parti de là et ensuite ça s'est
monté sur d'autres sujets mais la
difficulté elle était elle était bien
présente et nous on le savait les élus
qu'elle était bien présent de cette
difficulté
je vous rejoins je vous entends quand
vous dites que monsieur macron
effectivement notre président a souhaité
mettre en place le basque il avait dit
son programme qu'il avait dit mais on
savait pertinemment que ce serait très
difficile de le porter et de le mener à
bien donc aujourd'hui on se retrouve
devant une vraie difficulté
je dirais de l'ensemble par l'ibpt
l'ensemble des français vous représentez
pas peut-être l'ensemble des français
mais en tout cas une grande partie de la
population qui est en souffrance et il
est clair qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve
devant des difficultés qui sont des
difficultés qui vont nous poser souci
parce que les réponses que vous attendez
vont aussi déstabilisé énormément tout
ce qui n'est pas fait aujourd'hui pour
pouvoir équilibrer les finances de
l'état parce que la grande difficulté
elle est là c'est que répondent même
avec 10 milliards comme vous l'évoquez
ça peut paraître petit mais c'est déjà
très important par rapport à la dette de
l'état et je pense qu'il y avait des tas
de choses à faire aussi à ce niveau là
pour pouvoir vous accompagnez nous
accompagnent et accompagner les français
mieux mais en faisant d'abord tout une
réforme au niveau de l'état puisque les
élus sont des gens responsables et
aujourd'hui les maires les départements
les régions ont fait de grandes
économies l'état c'est pas ça pas été le
cas et depuis de nombreuses années je
suis pas en train de dire depuis le s
que vous avez où vous allez apporter vos
contributions en mairie
1.1 clore sa fille toi quand vous dites
qu effectivement emmanuel emmanuel
macron a choisi 35 points et enfin en
termes de sujets pour cent en débat moi
ce qui m'embête un petit peu la danse
c'est que la légitimité aurait dû
revenir aux revendications des gilet
jaune et c'est ça que tu aurais dû
composer le coeur du débat et non pas
des points qui fin ou du moins des
sujets qui ont été choisis et déterminé
par lui l'ensemble de son gouvernement
aujourd'hui je pense que les
revendications encore une fois sont très
claires en tout cas beaucoup de
revendications ressortent delà de la
part des villes et jaune notamment ce
qui va être une des principales le
hérissé citoyenne qui qui je pense peut
être peut apporter justement cette
restructuration du gouvernement
apporter du nouveau aussi et des
mécaniques nouvelles qui vont peut-être
rendre encore plus intelligent notre
mécanique gouvernementale alors que je
pouvais juste répondre à ma question
savoir si vous allez participer en fait
vraiment ce grand débat en apportant
votre contribution réduite bien sûr bien
évidemment je veux d'ailleurs rendre en
mairie pourriture belge veut dire ce que
ça c'est un point de face et je pense
que si on veut initier le changement
faut que tout le monde y participe donc
c'est important d'aller effectivement
porter son message personnel au sein des
différents canaux qui ont été mis à
disposition donc notamment les mairies
mais je pense qu'il faut encore aller
plus loin c'est à dire qu' il faut que
les revendications ne soient pas
uniquement transverses femmes passent
uniquement par le biais des mairies mais
aussi par des représentants
ou du moins des citoyens qu'ils soient
conviés à ce grand débat quoi qui ne
soit pas uniquement uniquement cantonnée
à la description
il y aura également des réunions avec
les associations avec les représentants
des syndicats parce que moi je souhaite
que les syndicats en tout cas de sud
yvelines de puisse participer aux
revendications puisque ces corps
intermédiaires sont là depuis très
longtemps dans les entreprises dans les
différentes branches d'activités pour
faire remonter les revendications
donc il y aura aussi ce type de réunion
encore une fois je pense que ce qui est
difficile c'est de généraliser sur tous
les territoires
vous avez par exemple des maires comme
madame qui sont partis très tôt qui
revendiquent eux effectivement le débat
et qui n'ont pas peur du débat et vous
avez aussi des mères il faut le dire
aussi sur notre département qui sont pas
confortables avec ce débat qui n'y vont
pas spontanément
voilà avec qui du coup vont peut-être
pas facilité dans leur ville
l'expression citoyenne sur sur toutes
les revendications franchement que les
revendications elles seront larges et
c'est pas les revendications des gilet
jaune c'est ce que vous vous avez
revendiqué mais c'est aussi tout ce que
les françaises et les français ont envie
de mettre sur la table dire quelque
chose qui est quand même qui me semble
très important j'entends tout ce que
vous dites mais aujourd'hui même si on
répondait à tous à tout cela il ya quand
même il ya quand même un tremblement qui
se met en place par rapport à nos
institutions
parce que vous parlez de représentation
vous parler effectivement de deux
modèles différents de méthodes
différentes pour vous exprimer
on a dans la vème république absolument
tous qui permet quand vous allez voter
pour un élu quand vous allez voter pour
un président ou un maire ou un député et
bien vous êtes véritablement dans la
représentation je dirais de votre droit
des lecteurs et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous dénoncez cela
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui d'après ce
qu'on entend ça ne vous correspond plus
donc ces frémissements des institutions
sont sont assez graves je dirais dans le
mode de fonctionnement en poche et que
tu sais moi mais j'ai cru entendre qu'au
niveau des gilet jaune y avait des
vraies difficultés pour nommer des
représentants
à un moment donné il faut des
représentants monsieur en état
j'en suis une il faut des représentants
sinon avec qui on parle
je veux dire voyez la problématique dont
qu'on accompagne ce débat ça me paraît
très important que le président macron
soit aujourd'hui à cette écoute pour
pouvoir éventuellement répondre je ne
pense pas qu'il puisse répondre à tous
parce que ça risque d'être très
compliqué mais il ya aussi cette base
des institutions qui est compliqué quand
on voit le peu de gens qui vont voter
quand il ya des élections ça pose
problème
la première autorité que l'on a en tant
que citoyen c'est le vote et à la
représentation justement ils ne trouvent
ils ne s'y retrouve pas en fait dans des
différents partis politiques qui se
présentent et notamment les différentes
personnes qui se présentent peut-être
qu'il ya aussi un réel problème
fondamental en fait qui fait que bâle on
a du mal à se représenter dans un parti
ou un autre vous sentez vous plus sympa
salariés avant d'être élu député en 2002
set j'étais salarié comme vous donc je
dirais les images enfin on attend que ça
quand vous regardez la représentation
nationale aujourd'hui il n'y a jamais eu
autant de renouvellement à l'assemblée
que en 2017 vous avez tous les corps qui
existent vous avez des agriculteurs et
des instituteurs vous avez des retraités
vous avez des cadres des ouvriers enfin
vous avez vraiment une représentation
qui a été totalement renouvelée et
c'était souvenez-vous en 2017 ou si
cette grande vague de dire on veut plus
d'élus qui sont là depuis 20 ans qui
connaissent pas notre c'est ça qui enfin
c'est ce que les français ont souhaité
moi j'ai envie de dire à un moment donné
à les y venaient surtout présenter vous
de ce canton pagne cet investissement
vient ce sens vraiment peut-être
effectivement est ce que parce que vous
disiez c'est que if it mans il ya une
abstention de voeux de vote qui est
assez importante en france
le problème je pense qu'il est il est
plus les plus fondamentales que ça sert
que je pense que les gens ont du mal
aujourd'hui à se représenter vraiment ou
du moins être
se sentir soutenu par un parti ou par un
autre même par une personnalité en fait
c'est là peut-être qu'ils aillent voir
peut-être justement que certaines idées
soient trop coloré politiquement parlant
moi moi aujourd'hui personnellement je
suis apolitique donc c'est pour moi j'ai
encore beaucoup de mal à me situer à me
sentir valorisés par tel ou tel parti
politique je pense qu'il ya du bien il
ya du mauvais dans plusieurs parties la
vraie difficulté c'est l'homogénéité des
justement des décisions et des buts
chose donc pour moi c'est compliqué mais
oui je pense que surveille la méthode
juste en un mot pour vous rassurer par
rapport à ça vous savez qu'après il est
prévu d'avoir des conventions régionales
avec des françaises et des français qui
sont tirés au sort et donc ils pourront
alors trier donner leur avis sur
l'ensemble des propositions donc ça
c'est vraiment une forme fallait plus
élémentaires de la démocratie ça qu'on
va tirer des gens au sort et ils vont
donner leur avis donc des gens
représentatifs comment justement bajal
et j'allais venir justement sur ce
déroulement du grand débat national
puisque ce sera à partir du 1er mars en
justement ces débats avec des français
tirés au sort sur quelles bases en fait
sur les listes électorales vont s'étirer
ouvert à ce moment là mais moi si je
prends le dernier exemple en date est
très très bien fonctionné c'est sûr sur
les la révision des lois de bioéthique
où il ya vingt-cinq français qui ont été
tirés au sort donc je rassure sur des
listes électorales et sur des français
qui participent déjà au monde associatif
25 français qui se connaissaient pas et
qui ont l'opportunité pendant cinq
semaines de travail et sur la révision
des lois de bioéthique et je peux vous
assurer qu'ils y connaît sait absolument
rien ils ont été formés ils ont été
accompagnés pendant ces cinq semaines
pour comprendre les enjeux des lois de
bioéthique et ils ont rendu des avis
clair précis sur ces sujets là tu
entends parler beaucoup de la pma de la
fin de vie je vous assure qu'ils ont
beaucoup éclairer le débat de manière
très sensée l'art ce seront des
conférences citoyennes régional
joséphine palmas berger vous en pensez
quoi justement ce que vous pensez qu
elles vont apporter quelque chose en
plus des doors des doléances je sais que
vous n'aimez pas ce terme
non je vais battre je suis malgré tout
un peu inquiète parce que je vais vous
dire oui j'entends quand vous dites on
voulait du renouvellement les maires ou
les où les députés qui étaient là depuis
vingt ans mais on se retrouve aussi avec
des personnes qui sont complètement hors
sol c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui si la
difficulté que nous avons aussi
aujourd'hui c'est que il ya plus deux
parties vous l'avez dit un président
macron a mis en place un mode de
fonctionnement je dirais qui a annihilé
les parties pourquoi pas c'était un mode
nouveau un gouvernement nouveau très
bien pas de souci j'ai dis d'ailleurs à
l'époque on va voir et puis on verra
bien y'a pas de soucis 1
il faut être en ouverture mais en tout
cas le hors-sol pose problème et pour
répondre à votre question c'est que
quand
effectivement vous avez des tirages au
sort c'est très bien c'est une forme
démocratique mais en même temps si
aujourd'hui on a aussi ce grand malaise
c'est peut-être aussi parce que on nous
a pas suffisamment écoutés nous les
personnes fin juin hier les élus qui
étions sur le terrain parce que s'il ya
bien des gens qui sont sur le terrain
c'est bien sommes quand même et on n'a
pas suffisamment écoutés on l'a dit
d'ailleurs au président d'un cran quand
elle a rencontré aussi senti
complètement dénigrer et complètement en
coupures
parce que aussi on a la connaissance de
beaucoup de choses on est tous les jours
sur le terrain on parle avec des gens
comme vous comme comme n'importe qui en
permanence et on fait remonter ça et
aujourd'hui on veut mettre en place un
mode de fonctionnement qui mode de
fonctionnement positionner sur le hasard
total et je ne dénigre pas les personnes
qui sont tirés au sort et je veux dire
il faut et vous l'avez dit vous-même il
faut les former
il faut les mettre au courant il faut
qu'ils s'inscrivent dans quelque chose
pour apporter quelque chose dont je suis
très inquiète parce que je me dis on a
des forces vives déjà en connaissant sur
le territoire et on ne s'en sert pas
c'est ce qu'on a dit au président je dis
aujourd'hui excusez moi chers collègues
il est tout le respect que j'ai pour
vous bien sûr mais les députés
aujourd'hui moi j'en connais beaucoup
qui sont là depuis très peu de temps
voilà il faut qu'il prenne le temps il
faut qu'ils apprennent il faut qu'il se
passe sur le terrain ils nous disent des
choses qu'on sait déjà depuis longtemps
donc ça aussi ça nous a un peu coupé ça
nous a coupé de vous les députés ça nous
a coupé du président et on lui a dit
donc c'est bien de vouloir renouveler de
changer mais il ne jette je tombe pas je
veux dire l'eau du bain et avec le bébé
est tout en disant que tout ce qui était
en place précédemment était très mauvais
appuyons-nous ressources sur les
connaissances de ceux qui sont là donc
pour répondre à votre question je suis
très inquiète les miss oui l'émission
tous justement bientôt à sa fin on va on
va commencer à à conclure je filais
réaliste d'une question concernant les
interventions donc de certains noms
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je ne pense
pas à intervenir dans ce type de débat
pourquoi parce que il n'y a pas de
il n'y a pas toutes les revendications
qui sont indiqués dans ce qui dans les
axes par exemple vérifier le rich et qui
pourrait être c'est la solution pour
l'une des solutions ont parlé d'
abstention
donc qu'est-ce qui pourrait à mon sens
et j'en parle et je parle comme on nous
donnait le comment dire donner la force
le l'envi aux citoyens d'aller voter
d'aller voter des lois de contribuer etc
c'est le riz qu il fait peur en quoi le
recteur on a l'impression que vous avez
déjà voté j'ai lu des députés des
sénateurs et sanatop grands électeurs
pour faire ce travail d'une heure se
tromper et de mettre des mécaniques
justement dans le cas où nous verrons
pas soyons honnêtes entre nous si vous
posez la question est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faut augmenter le smic cette année
moi je connais déjà la réponse est pas
besoin du rich pour ça et dans la
constitution du budget de la france qui
est un exercice extrêmement difficile
parce que vous avez le budget de la
france c'est le même fromage qu'on
aurait pâti chaque année entre entre
tout le monde donc si tout le monde veut
une augmentation à un moment donné un
référendum au pas de référendum je
connais déjà par avance la réponse donc
c'est plutôt sain qui moi je crois pas
que c'est la panacée de référendum
il est prévu dans la constitution est
d'ailleurs le référendum quand il s'agit
de toucher aux institutions
on demande l'avis aux françaises et aux
français on pourra pas demander l'avis
aux français surtout si ça serait pas
possible
vraiment les choses seront bloqués on
n'avancera pas quand vous faites un
budget ces deux mois de travail à
l'assemblée nationale fait des centaines
de milliards qui sont débattues avec des
lignes budgétaires infinie vous imaginez
s'il faut demander l'avis à chaque
français sur chacune des lignes il faut
deux ans et demi pour voter un budget
moins techniquement ça marche pas et il
reste très peu de temps 30 secondes
chacun
par exemple samedi s qui aura un acte
disent encore des gilet jaune
moi je encore fois je
je peux pas parler au nom des idéaux ne
fait partie du mouvement
moi personnellement je pense que je vais
continuer effectivement la mobilisation
de mon côté parce que je pense que c'est
important et qu'aujourd'hui si je
reviens très rapidement sur le discours
enfin le débat grand débat cueillir moi
j'ai eu affaire à une personne qui qui
qui utilisent un vocabulaire de
technocrates je n'ai pas compris la
moitié de ce qu'il disait et je pense
que la moitié des français n'ont pas
compris non plus qui ce qu'il expliquait
dans la majeure partie de ces
discussions
donc oui je vais continuer à mobiliser
parce que moi je suis certain
aujourd'hui en tout cas au début de ce
grand débat que ça ne va pas apporter ou
faire bouger beaucoup les choses
donc oui je vais continuer à mobiliser
et j'invite effectivement mes confrères
à le faire aussi joséphine kama de
s'immerger vous avez dit être inquiète
mais néanmoins vous vous organiser un
débat donc bien sûr bien sûr en tant qu'
en tant que mais oui républicaine est en
pleine démocratie
jeffrey skilling je respecte le
président de la république est en place
je vous rejoins quand on dit il a été
élu allons-y bien sûr jusqu'au bout et
on va accompagner tout cela parce qu'il
ya une vraie souffrance et il faut le
faire mais soyons vigilants malgré tout
parce que je j'ai quand même la
sensation que les choses ne sont pas
aussi clairs que ça dans les demandes et
dans les attentes et qu' il va falloir
être très vigilant parce qu'on est en
train de de malmener notre république et
notre démocratie
-d cheikh samb 10 secondes que va t-il
se paie 10 secondes que va-t-il se
passer après le 15 mars
mais il va falloir compilé toutes les
demandes regardez avec des conférences
régionales qu est-ce qu est-ce qui est
retenue et quel impact ça va avoir sur
les lois qui doivent être débattues
cette année pour les modifier parce que
l'idée de faire un grand débat c'est pas
pour faire de la communication c'est
bien pour que c'est un impact direct sur
les lois que nous avons prévu de
discuter en 2019 en 2020 donc un impact
direct sur notre travail
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci en tout cas à tous les quatre
d'avoir été présent sur ce plateau on se
retrouve mercredi prochain pour un
nouveau s est huit débats à très bientôt
[Musique]
me